what's going on guys this is rob and as
predicted she-hulk episode 1 was amazing
[Laughter]
i will run over different easter eggs
and things like that that happen over
the course of the show but all in all it
was a great episode i absolutely loved
the first episode i laughed i cried over
how bad the she-hulk cgi was i just had
a great time you know in in some ways
and i know it wasn't their intention but
in some ways it feels like a low-budget
sci-fi
like movie or show it obviously wasn't
low budget like it cost a ton of money
to make but it just feels kind of like
that right it's just campy and like you
can't take it seriously which makes
sense because she-hulk was never a
superhero that anybody could take
seriously it was just one of those
things where it was like i mean you know
like
she's there and does stuff sometimes and
she's had like three great moments in
her character's history one of which is
when she met the living tribunal for
like two seconds but outside of that
right i mean it's just kind of like hey
whatever man like it's it's she exists
you know like she's a thing that exists
but the show itself i think where where
the she-hulk comics have consistently
just never made her interesting the show
makes her wildly fascinating i'm really
interested in it and i have to say like
the origin story that she got it has to
be some kind of record right i mean i
there's never been a time where i've
ever seen an origin story happen that
fast she's like so like we were driving
down the road and like it's a car and
spaceship appeared out of nowhere we got
into a car wreck i got cut banner blood
into me and then boom i'm she-hulk now
done and done and it's just like wow
that was quick that oh that was really
fast right like it was you know it was a
quick origin but honestly i love that it
was that fast i love that it was that
quick in a lot of ways i kind of get
burned out on the idea that they take
like a whole episode to explain a
person's origin right like what makes
she-hulk interesting you know i guess
what passes for interesting in the
comics is like her trying to balance the
life between being a lawyer and like
being the hulk and the fact that she's
like a lawyer for superheroes in the
comics but in this i love the whole
thing of her just like picking up the
swing of what it means to be a hulk
right off the bat and one of the things
that i do love that i think is going to
be a plot point that comes back later on
is how quickly she just kind of brushes
off basically everything she's been
taught by banner because even though you
do have them just sort of reconciling
and like banners trying to tell her hey
look like you have to understand with
this level of power that you have you
could just get mad one day and like
people will die like a town of people
could be killed or you could destroy a
building and it could collapse on top of
like tons of innocent people the amount
of collateral damage you can create just
by being irritated and just transforming
into your she-hulk she-hulk form and not
being able to control it it's very very
dangerous and you'll start drawing the
attention of all kinds of the wrong
people government agents different
organizations that want to like harvest
you for your power like kill you take
your blood that kind of a thing there's
a lot of stuff that can come out of it
so while she did initially sort of just
kind of blow all that off to a degree
she still kind of has now we don't
necessarily know how things sort of fit
in between the ending of the episode or
the ending of the origin that we got and
where she picks up in the courtroom a
few things may have likely happened in
between in fact the show might probably
go back and revisit some of those in
terms of flashbacks i'm not entirely
sure but all in all the show was fun i
had a great time watching it was an
absolute blast it was every bit as fun
as i hoped it would be i'm excited to
see where things go some of the moments
in the show were a little bit weird i
will say like when she was standing
outside dressed as a hooker and then
like those guys walk up and like they
start giving her a hard time i mean i
guess it makes sense they would have
done that it would have seemed just a
little uninteresting if they had been
like hey are you okay and she's like
yeah i'm waiting on my cousin they're
like okay cool and they get in their car
and drive away i guess that would have
been a very like interesting thing i
guess an interesting moment for her to
transform i don't really know why they
went with that but the whole point that
i'm making here is the show it's it's
like anything else it's got some
questionable moments where it's kind of
like i don't really know right titania
just like busts into the courtroom
looking like a wrestler from the 1980s
who also happens to like moonlight as a
prostitute but outside of that there
were like a few things that were kind of
like
this it is what it is but having said
that when it came to the easter eggs in
this right when it came to the easter
eggs in this whole thing there were a
ton of them right probably the one that
everybody's talking about is the
question that we get answered as to
whether or not captain america died a
virgin now let me tell you something man
even if we didn't find out that captain
america had like bang peggy carter which
of course we know that he basically had
at the very least when he went back and
lived his life i could almost guarantee
you that he banged emily vancamp's
character in the mcu there's no way it
didn't happen i mean look at the two of
them like how they interact in like
falcon in the winter enough falcon
winter soldier and uh captain america in
the winter soldier i mean you know they
were probably knocking boots but outside
of that we get an answer to that where
it's like nope he actually lost his
virginity like some random chick on on
like a on a carrier right like he it
happened in like 1940 was it 42 43 i
remember what they said but like it
happened right so like he didn't die a
virgin which is kind of funny right it's
cool that we finally got an answer to
that it was interesting that they gave
us that in a post-credits scene which
i'm surprised to see that like there's
even a post-credits scene in the first
episode i feel like a lot of the shows
have kind of gone into this pattern of
like you don't get a post-credits scene
until like the second half of the show's
run so i'm glad to see even if it was
just a comedic moment we got that little
post-credits scene there i love the
scene actually fit in with the overall
tone of the show the kind of campy
comedic tone of the show so far as far
as titania goes i'm curious to see what
they do with her because in the comics
she got her origins or got got her
powers from doctor doom not only that
titania actually had a role in secret
wars the original secret wars uh in
1984. i mean i don't know if she's gonna
have any role in like the avengers
secret wars film and honestly i doubt
she does i think she'll just be another
like another casualty of marvel studios
inability to make their video their
villains interesting so like i think
that's what's going to go on there she
may survive and go on and go on to the
future of things but i'm not entirely
sure where her journey is going to take
her there was of course like the whole
clap right that was really cool that
kind of came out wrong the hulk has the
clap there was not that
the thundercloth that the hulk does that
was a cool thing right that was a cool
little moment it's one of those small
things that you get to see and then you
see she-hulk do her own variation of it
now i think that highlights one of the
cool things about she-hulk is that she's
not a copy pasta version of the
incredible hulk if she if marvel studios
had done that if they had been like
here's she-hulk who's just a copy of
bruce banner it would have just taken
away from any interesting any interest
in her character whatsoever but instead
of having like the strength of the
incredible hulk which i think this
illustrates that she is strong but she's
not as strong as the incredible hulk
which makes sense that's the way it
always was in the comics like like bruce
banner as the incredible hulk was always
the strongest of all the different hulks
right like abomination and and like doc
samson and she-hulk and you know red
she-hulk which is what betty ross became
and like any of those versions of the
hulk out there he was always the
strongest of them so i'm glad they
maintained that but to compensate for
that it basically was she-hulk using the
ability to just create a huge tidal wave
of sounds that in turn just like almost
crippled bruce banner right brought him
to his knees i loved the city i love
that they did that i thought that was
really really cool of course we also got
like the references to like avengers and
thor ragnarok that kind of made sense we
sort of expected that and even with
banner i expected that to a degree right
once she did like a flashback and said
okay so i was on a drive with my cousin
i was certainly expecting there to be
like some discussion back and forth
about the kind of things that happened i
like that they skipped over that to be
honest with you guys and i know that
might be a little bit of a controversial
statement i use the phrase controversial
loosely because i can't think of another
word to use besides that that's not
controversial at all by any standard of
measurement but i imagine there might be
some folks who kind of gripe about it a
little bit we know the story of the
incredible hulk we know the story of
banner we've been following it for 10
years we don't need it told back to us
again
so i like that they basically skipped
over that and she's literally just like
wow you know that's a great great big
huge long-winded answer to the question
what have you been getting into so i
definitely dig that whole thing uh
something that i also thought was really
really interesting and i think this is
really a reference to what will become
the really the world war hulk event
likely leading out of planet hulk or
something out of those lines it's when
they're visited by like the zakar and
ship right the one that shows up in the
first place what's likely happening here
is that the the people of sakaar are
trying to get bruce banner to be like
this a carson right to like come back
and be the ruler of zakar now whether
that's because the car itself has fallen
into a state of like civil war whether
it's because of the fact they see him as
still like the best person to lead
because he was their champion for so
long whatever the reason is that's
likely what's happening here now whether
or not that leads to him actually
traveling back to sakaar things unfold
by whatever manner and whatever means
and that leads to the events of like
world war hulk i'm not entirely sure i
don't think there are any there's
there's really no major news coming out
about world war hulk outside of like
it's an idea that marvel studios is
kicking around and may end up becoming a
tv show at some point outside of that
like there's really nothing going on
there so i imagine that question will
likely be answered as far as the
she-hulk show goes outside of that i
don't really know where they would have
a place to answer that question it would
seem really weird if we get like a
second post-credits scene in ant-man
quantum mania where like bruce banner
shows up once a car and it's like i will
be your sir carson like it would just
feel out of place this is the best place
to handle that if that does happen
that'll probably happen at the end of
the show or at the very least we'll get
an answer to the question of what's
going on with the people of sakhar and
it's most likely them wanting him to
become this carson so i'm kind of
curious to see where that goes one of
the things is also kind of strange here
and i'm not entirely sure how to make of
this
that bruce banner actually used the
blood of jennifer walters to heal
himself because of just the unique way
in which she handles gamma radiation
this might be one of those caveats there
but the incredible hulk already has a
healing factor and it's one of those
things that just never really quite sat
with me very well in the sense that like
his arm was broken and like it's finally
healed because he could use gamma
radiation that like what would
essentially happen here because it's the
way it plays out in the comics what
would happen is that like if bruce
banner for example his like bruce banner
the human form his arm was broken he
would turn to the hulk the healing
factor would heal his arm and then he'd
go right back to being bruce banner and
his arm would be healed right his bone
would be set it wouldn't go back it's
not as though he would turn into the
hulk the hulk's arm's fine he goes back
into banner and like his bone breaks as
he's transitioning back because you know
continuity it doesn't really work that
way so it's one of those things that
just never quite sat with me in that way
i always thought it was a little strange
that may have been something they were
just kind of setting aside so that we
they could basically focus on the i
guess enhanced healing factor of
jennifer walters and what it all means
you know whether it means that she's
just more capable it's just kind of her
benefit of being the hulk because for
the most part when it comes to the
different variations of the hulk they
all have their own benefits right so
like red hulk emits high levels of heat
bruce banner of course has like infinite
strength she-hulk can break the fourth
wall and be relevant occasionally in the
comics right abominations just super
strong and huge there's all kinds of
different things these little small
little caveats that they have although i
guess more recently in the comics the
incredible hulk is now the immortal hulk
the devil hulk so technically he can
never die he'll always come back to life
no matter what happens but regardless
it's these these small little easter
eggs and these small little moments that
go into this that i absolutely love
hey guys rob was already on a trip when
he noticed this detail he had missed
irony i know but the gamma dna sequencer
that was developed by bruce banner and
tony stark looks like the dna sequencer
that showed up in grant morrison's new
x-men this story explained the different
programs from weapons plus in marvel
comics weapon tan or weapon x being
wolverine this doesn't necessarily mean
that it's a direct reference to
wolverine but this could definitely
circle back around in the mcu later on
and yeah that's all i got back to rob of
course one of the other things that we
found that i'm actually not a big fan of
it or i guess maybe i am but i'm not
bruce banner refers to himself as the
smart hulk instead of the professor hulk
now that's not a terrible thing and the
reason why is because the professor hulk
is an actual version of the hulk that
exists so that might be something that
they're saving because when it comes to
professor hulk that was basically the
result of what happened when bruce
banner and the different variations of
the incredible hulk all basically had a
kind of mental truce in terms of like
what you see in the mcu right now
regarding banner and the main hulk and
that in turn once they kind of merge
together in a singular personality
that's where you got professor hulk from
so essentially it was all the
intelligence of bruce banner combined
with the unlimited strength of the
incredible hulk which is kind of what
you see here with smart hulk there's
somebody just not calling him that so i
don't know if it's one of those things
where instead of saying professor hulk
it's smart hulk they both mean the same
thing or if it's one of those where
they're literally holding professor hulk
off because there's other hulk
personalities that they're going to
introduce later on down the line gray
hulk joe fix it devil hulk all that kind
of stuff and then we'll end up seeing
them kind of converge into one version
which ends up becoming the professor
hulk again i don't necessarily know if
that's going to be the case but we also
got small little moments here right like
iron man's helmet was broken which was
maintained by bruce banner that's one of
the things that i loved about the show
is that it focused a lot on the
relationship between bruce and tony
which i didn't really even know existed
i mean you knew they were like friends
and they hung out i mean you could tell
that from like the first avengers that
if for no other reason than just the
intelligence they shared there was
camaraderie there i mean we saw that in
like avengers age of ultron the two of
them worked on projects together but we
didn't know how far reaching their
friendship was if it was just kind of
like professional respect and like the
friendship that comes with being an
avenger and that's where it ends but the
idea of tony stark like building a whole
facility for bruce banner the fact that
like bruce banner built a bar tony stark
just sat there and got drunk and watched
it all obviously they were incredibly
close as far as friends went so much so
that bruce banner kept the helmet of
tony stark and most likely it was
probably given to him right it was
probably like in the last will and
testament of tony make sure banner gets
my helmet right that kind of a thing so
i do love that whole relationship
between the two of them i loved the way
that unfolded now as far as what we'll
end up seeing in the future of the
marvel cinematic universe i'm not
entirely sure when it comes to she-hulk
right i don't know exactly how
everything is going to play out the
character as she's presented in the show
is for the most part pretty true to form
with the comics right that unlike bruce
banner who turns into the incredible
hulk and it's literally a whole other
personality and they just don't really
like each other that she hulk and
jennifer walters are effectively the
same thing right that like literally
jennifer walters turns into she-hulk and
maintains herself so it's really her
just being granted access to powers but
still maintaining herself in the process
so the way that she works now it's
really no different than somebody who
suddenly emerges with like telepathy or
telekinesis or something like that it's
just a power they can use she just
happens to get bigger and change colors
when she does that's basically it i do
like that it is very very true to form i
don't know if they're going to go to the
direction of these of really the kind of
stories we got like the old fantastic
four stories or what have you where she
basically lost her ability to become
jennifer walters and was stuck in her
she-hulk form depending on how they want
things to go or their character if what
they're looking to do is keep mark
ruffalo around and basically have him
stay as the incredible hulk in the
marvel cinematic universe for the
foreseeable future there's ample things
they can do they can throw him on the
defenders and they can put jennifer
walters on the avengers assuming that we
actually get a tried and true defenders
team the makings are there right name of
the submariner is in is going to be in
black panther 2. the silver surfer will
arrive when black panther i'm sorry when
a galactic appears in the mcu you've
already got doctor strange so it's most
likely that we're going to end up seeing
the defenders in that way even if it's
not perfectly true to comics you've
already kind of got the trappings that
are there for the team to be made it
could also be one of those things where
banner stays on the avengers and that
she-hulk ends up becoming a part of the
fantastic four maybe something happens
to ben grimm and that's it right you go
into like avengers secret wars ben grimm
can't be the thing anymore he's stuck in
his human form whatever the case is
she-hulk takes his place it's what
happened in the comics so it makes
perfect sense by the way if you see
anybody get mad about the idea of
she-hulk replacing ben graham on the
fantastic four you immediately know that
person has never read comics because
that's exactly what happens in the
comics so do not take that person
seriously but outside of that i'm
curious to see where things go for her
character i do love the show i'm having
a great time watching it i'm excited to
see what happens in the next few
episodes so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section did
you guys enjoy the show i'm sure there
are people who are going to be like
women are bad this show sucks i mean i'm
sure you're going to see some of those
but barring people who are just being
outrageously angry about something that
doesn't make any sense to be
outrageously angry about what did you
think about it i'm excited to see it but
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace